That's so cool. Look,
an abortion clinic. Yeah,
no, that's a.
That's a fake abortion clinic.
What are you talking about?
It says free pregnancy test.
It says women's clinic.
They'll lure pregnant women with free pregnancy tests
and free ultrasounds, but they're really just there to,
like, talk you out of getting an abortion.
There's, like,
doctors in there, right?
They'll walk around with lab coats and pretend like they're doctors,
but they're not. Okay,
well, I guess if they're just giving out information,
they can't really hurt anybody.
The information they were giving out was actually correct.
But one study found that 87% of them lied to women,
telling them that abortion causes, like,
breast cancer. Damn.
Wow. Okay,
so a lot of them must be, like,
shutting down. Actually,
more and more of them are opening.
Okay, so the government must be trying to cut the funding.
No, the government actually funds them.
What, 2022 alone,
they got, like,
$1.4 billion in taxpayer funded money.
But there's not, like,
more fake clinics than real abortion clinics, though, right?
Yeah. For every real clinic,
there's three fake ones. Wow.
Okay, so they have a lot of information about pregnant women.
They're keeping all of that private thing.
Even though it's a fake clinic,
they still have to respect HIPAA.
There's not even, like,
a data breach or something?
I gotta go.